un premier boeing 747 en corse depuis ce
matin l'aéroport d'ajaccio qui a été
agrandi peut donc accueillir les avions
gros porteurs satisfaction des
professionnels du voyage et du tourisme
et inquiétudes de certains élus qui ne
veulent pas du tourisme de masse sur
l'île de beauté au reportage jacques
garnier et marque doux avec
l'allongement de sa piste principale
portait à 2418 m l'aéroport d'ajaccio
campo dell'oro souffre depuis
aujourd'hui aux gros porteurs
un boeing 747 de la compagnie corsair
s'est posé pour la première fois ce
matin 11
désormais la piste ajaccienne va pouvoir
accueillir des 747 ou des a300 en
provenance non seulement du continent
mais aussi de l'europe entière
elle avait ses premiers gros porteurs
et tant pis pour la france parce que ça
nous évitera des ruptures de charge
soliste maceio paris et ça permettra
l'apport d'avoir un accès direct aux
litiges après qu'est-ce que ça va
apporter à la corse
ça devrait nous apporter quand même
un supplément de clientèle cardiaque et
surtout de communes espérant et ce pour
quoi le monde attend une quarantaine
durant nord et premiers travaux
commencés en 1988 représente un
investissement global de 25 millions de
francs
objectif à atteindre un million de
passagers dans les deux ans à venir avec
en projet la construction d'un nouvel
aérogare mais pour l'instant le tourisme
de masse en corse pose quelques
interrogations
un touriste intelligent ça veut dire pas
de tourisme de masse ça veut dire un
développement progressif sur le plan de
l'hôtellerie développer les locations de
voiture développée
les randonnées les circuits les
excursions certains élus ce matin ont
boudé la conférence de presse le
partenariat en corse a bien du mal à
décoller incendies de forêts dans le
midi le plus important